bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir cap sur les
législatives tous les partis politiques
sont dans la course lr om est reine elle
est fille qui des trois grands blocs qui
composent désormais le paysage politique
a le plus de chances de victoire en juin
prochain les français voudront ils
redonner une majorité confortable à
l'assemblée à emmanuel macron et quid
des républicains leur refus d'alliance
acté aujourd'hui va-t-il les faire
disparaître législatives des inconnus du
troisième tour c'est notre grand
décryptage dans un instant sur ce
plateau notre grand témoin vient de
publier un livre passionnant et d'une
actualité stupéfiante pendant quatre ans
il a enquêté en russie sur celui qu'il
nomme le mage du kremlin vladislav
surkov le conseiller énigmatique à de
vladimir poutine pionnier de la
stratégie du chaos reprise par bon
nombre de leaders populistes il est
romancier il est un essayiste et il
s'appelle giuliano dahan police avec
nous ce soir enfin dans cette émission
retour des affranchis pour leur parti
pris ce soir jean rémi baudot nous dit
tout de ce que prépare emmanuel macron
pour son deuxième quinquennat
fanny guinochet pas d'état de grâce pour
le président élu à la veille du défilé
du 1er mai des syndicats et puis le
rachat du géant twitter par le
milliardaire elon musk à la loupe de
delphine sabattier voilà pour le menu
c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs la bataille est lancée
depuis dimanche soir rarement les
législatives ont eu autant d'enjeux
alors on va essayer d'y voir un peu plus
clair la seule certitude c'est que pour
gagner il faut s'allier bonsoir pascal
perrineau je suis bien venu vous êtes
politologue au cevipof de sciences po
ravi vous retrouver sur ce plateau
bonsoir guillaume tabard ravi également
rédacteur en chef et éditorialiste
politique au figaro votre dernier livre
macron la révolution inachevée chez
robert laffont qui est toujours
totalement d'actualité bonsoir mathieu
gallard et bienvenue directeur d'études
à l'institut de sondages ipsos stéphanie
des pierres de la rédaction de lcp qui
suit les républicains va nous rejoindre
dans un instant il y avait un comité
stratégique important ce matin mais on
va commencer avec l'oeil de blacko trois
blocs aux législatives qu'est ce que ça
donne si j'ai bien compris stéphane
blakowski mesdames et messieurs
[Musique]
nous sans myriam bonsoir messieurs si
j'ai bien compris ce soir si j'ai bien
compris myriam c'est reparti pour un
tour c'est à dire que l'on vient de
choisir un président mais dans deux mois
va falloir à nouveau jeu plaisir macron
le pen ou bien mélenchon parce que c'est
comme ça maintenant on choisit au moins
autant dé personnalités finalement que
des idées je pas fille quelques uns je
sais qu'il est du calibre ce soir me
définir ce que cette le maquereau nice
mais non même macro le bain il s'est
même peut-être pas trop où exactement ce
que c'est mais le grand six essais sur
france inter thomas legrand disent qu'il
n'a jamais réussi après cinq ans
d'études ah bon vous voyez que c'est pas
si simple et d'ailleurs même re o arn et
voilà france insoumise sans mélenchon
sent marine le pen qui est ce qui reste
jordan et adrien voilà bon il ya quand
même trois blocs politiques qui se
détache la fameuse théorie les trois
blocs on l'entend partout celle là
d'ailleurs semble avoir tellement
imprégné les idées que le premier
institut de sondage qui s'est risqué à
faire un sondage il a immédiatement
adopté
philippe des trois blocs l'avantagé que
c'est facile à lire macron une majorité
absolue à gauche c'est mélenchon à
droite c'est le pen donc ça voudrait
dire que les républicains pourrait
totalement disparaître
invite donc ses images
enfin mais oui mais la route près du
caire ont disparu mais qu'est ce que
c'est gérard majax ou quoi pas
franchement alors moi je suis étonné
quand même un groupe de 100 députés
comme ça qui disparaîtraient d'un
claquement de doigts
lesquels sont implantés localement c'est
eux qui ont le plus de régions en france
ceux qui ont plus de départements voyez
qu'on va les rayer de cartes ré de la
carte comme ça d'un d'un trait de plume
s'il reste bien regroupés avant
législatif ce n'est pas évident et ils
ont l'air de vouloir rester gros pire
comme anti en écoute peut pas être les
républicains et majorité présidentielle
on ne peut pas être les républicains et
reconquête on ne peut pas être les
républicains et et horizons on est les
républicains un groupe indépendant alors
attention je dis pas qu'ils vont rester
unis après les législatives
effectivement mais je dirais que les
républicains fasse élire 30 députés avec
un groupe c à partir de quinze députés
donc avec 30 députés peuvent former deux
groupes un qui voteraient macron il
voterait locale voilà vous êtes un cas
ce soir et le bloc de gauche alors le
blog de quoi de gauche ah non mais moi
j'en crois pas de mots dont je connais
pas de sens à meriem c'est un principe
dans les chronos c'est une question de
confiance avec le public voie de gauche
je sais pas ce que ça veut dire c'est
pour ou contre le nucléaire c'est pour
ou contre l'europe il ya plein de
questions où on n'arrive pas trop à
savoir pour conques et livraisons
d'armes à l'ukraine d'ailleurs ce matin
il y avait gagné jadot qui était sur
france inter yannick jadot c'est le
monsieur qui était candidate pour les
écologistes tout le monde se souvient il
mais pourtant il n'a pas l'air dans tout
ce qu'il a fait un petit score soit ça
n'a pas l'air de vouloir se rallier à
mélenchon je soutiens cette perspective
de coalition qui doit être une coalition
très ouverte vous entendez la france
info 12h10 on est ouvert on tend la main
mais derrière nous derrière jean luc
mélenchon peut pas ça marchera pas mais
ça marchera pas si je vous dis lui chef
la non non ben voilà les fondamentaux de
la politique c'est les mêmes que ceux de
la cour de récré on dirait que ce serait
moi le chef et l'autre répond non c'est
pas toi le chef voilà on en est à gauche
d'ailleurs les socialistes vont je crois
qu'il ya un peu tractations en cours
mais a déjà toute une partie du ps cas
pas du tout envie de se rallier
mélenchon c'est stéphane le foll le
porte flingue de françois hollande qui
en parle le mieux donc françois l'on
doit être tapis dans l'ombre quand on
dit ça j'ai prévenu que la stratégie de
l'effacement c'est une tragi quiconque
qui
aboutit à l'effacement électorale et que
là se ranger derrière jean-luc mélenchon
ces dépassements finale mais finalement
qu'est ce qui reste alors des trois
blocs et ben je sais pas il reste
peut-être le bloc là le pen de la droite
nationale mais même ils sont un peu
fissurée enfin ils sont censés si on les
additionne les 21 et 7 % au premier tour
faire à peu près 30% se trouve que une
faconde pas si bien car la droite
nationale deschamps ne supporte pas
l'arrogance de la droite nationale des
villes on les écoutait ce matin loulou
qui parlait on peut pas dire en même
temps lui aussi
à cause de marine le pen on perd les
élections présidentielles et puis dans
la phrase d'après dire oui mais bon
d'accord on fait pour sauver notre peau
veux bien une alliance avec vous faut
être juste cohérent modeste et avoir un
peu d'humilité ce qui manque à mon avis
eric zemmour est oui l'arrogance d'eric
zemmour on n'en parle pas assez bons en
tant qu'éleveur congrès explique être à
bloc parce que moi j'ai
mais qui ne sont qu'à voir quelques
fissures way dans les blogs merci
beaucoup vous entrez dans ce décor bien
planté avec votre regard stéphane alors
justement ya plein de choses avant de
partir sur les différents partis
politiques les différents blocs déjà
pascal perrineau est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'avec la donne
présidentielle
on peut s'attendre à une assemblée bien
différente déjà d'il ya cinq ans on
c'est plus compliqué que ça on peut
avoir une assemblée qui sera différente
bien différente je me pose la question
pourquoi parce que depuis la réforme du
quinquennat depuis l'inversion du
calendrier électoral qui fait que les
législatives viennent forcément
après la présidentielle quelques
semaines mon là ça sera dans la deuxième
quinzaine de juin les élections
législatives reçoivent leur principe de
fonctionnement de l'élection matrice de
l'élection mère qui est l'élection
présidentielle ce sont des élections
seconde ce sont des élections qui
s'organise dans l'ombre et dans laquelle
on assiste en général toujours au même
mouvement les électeurs des oppositions
se démobilisent parce qu'il considère
que la messe est dite et les électeurs
de la majorité qui a gagné se mobilisent
un peu mieux que les électeurs de l'opus
avec 3e tour comme on l'est par les
danses
à chaque fois je vous ferai remarquer un
parce que déjà la dernière fois en 2017
on entendait mélenchon nous tenir ce
type de discours on entendait marine le
pen nous tenir ce type de discours et à
la fin des fins le et rennes n'a même
pas pu avoir son groupe parlementaire et
la france insoumise a eu tout juste son
groupe parlementaire donc je ne dis pas
que ça finira de la même manière 1 mais
le fait que la macro ni dans sa
diversité parce que il faut que c'était
très intéressant d'assister sur les
fractionnement des différents pôles le
pôle de la macro ni il va explorer sa
diversité en interne on va le voir des
gens mais bien sûr on va le voir déjà
dans les investitures et on va le voir
aussi de temps en temps dans de
nombreuses circonscriptions dans son
incapacité à devenir une force vraiment
locale parce que les élections
légistatives certes ce sont des
élections nationales mais qui se font
sur 577 scène locale
pas uniquement les poids lourds de la
macro ni en dépit de cinq ans par là les
poids lourds de la macro ni sauf ici ou
là il n'existe pas les poids lourds de
france insoumise n'existe souffre ici ou
là n'existent pas et
l'international même chose les
républicains les socialistes faut pas
oublier les socialistes il avait été
écrasé la dernière fois ils ont eu un
groupe ils ont un ancrage local
d'ailleurs on en parlera avec stéphanie
des pierre bonsoir et bienvenue vous
avez assisté à ce comité stratégique
enfin c'était à huis clos a précisé ce
matin au siège du parti on va y revenir
dans un instant mathieu guenat alors vos
collègues d'harris interactive
ils ont fait ce sondage expliqué par
stéphane des projections en sièges sur
la base des résultats de la
présidentielle
on va revoir ce sondage pour la majorité
326 à 3 166 sièges 117 à 147 pour le
rassemblement national 73 à 90 pour
l'union de la gauche qui n'est pas à ce
stade acte et
efi pc et europe ecologie les verts à ce
que c'est pertinent de faire ça parce
que c'est bien fait ou pas à ce stade
c'est difficile de construire sondages
fiables sur les élections législatives
mais déjà ça a un avantage par rapport à
ce qu'on a beaucoup vu ces derniers
jours c'est que ça n'est pas une
projection basée sur les résultats du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle ce qui pour le coup n'a
véritablement aucun sens c'est un
sondage qui si j'ai bien compris ce
qu'ont fait mes collègues d'harris
interactive se base sur les intentions
de vote des électeurs aux élections
législatives de juin prochain la
difficulté c'est que effectivement à ce
stade on ne connaît pas les listes de
candidats des principaux partis on ne
connaît d'ailleurs pas encore les
configurations d'alliance que ce soit à
gauche que ce soit à l'extrême droite ce
que vont faire les républicains et donc
comme ça a été très bien dit par pascal
perrineau il ya une dynamique nationale
dans les élections législatives qui est
incontestable mais il ya aussi une
dynamique locale les républicains les
socialistes ont des sortants qui sont
bien implantés et qui peuvent résister
éventuellement à une vague contre leur
parti mais quand même parce qu'une
petite centaine une petite centaine
député gauche de la gauche s'est pas
complètement inconcevable c'est juste
pour essayer de voir ce qui peut nous
attend dans les scénarios
noida barça peut être à la fois beaucoup
moins et ça peut être beaucoup plus
mature gala le rappelle très justement
pour faire des projections qui a un sens
sur les châtie ville faut connaître les
configurations d'alliance pour être très
concret et qu'on comprenne bien dans une
même circonscription
si on a une union de la gauche qui se
fait sert que la france insoumise les
communistes les socialistes les
écologistes décide de soutenir un seul
candidat si ce candidat unique fait
mettons 30% il peut se qualifier au
second tour et potentiellement battre un
candidat de droite ou en marché sa et
mène dans une région qui est très à
gauche dont le potentiel de gauche
serait de 40 à 45% si chacun près dans
son candidat parce qu'il veut d'abord se
compter et ne pas céder la place à
l'autre on peut avoir trois ou quatre
candidats qui va chacun 12 13 ans 15
missionnaires à l'état serait déboursée
que dans une foire d'ailleurs donc sujet
sur le mode cristiano sera finalement
que l approche du premier tour et
peut-être même d'entre deux tours en
fonction aussi des jeux de 2-2 et quand
même vous montrer cette affiche vous
l'avez forcément vu cette affiche il est
fort en communication un jean luc
mélenchon après avoir lancé aux français
élisez moi premier ministre la voici
mélenchon premier ministre avec les
dates des législatives c'est bien joué
ça ça peut marcher quand on regarde
certains sondages alors évidemment c'est
dans la dynamique de la présidentielle
les français majoritairement ipsos le
montre aujourd'hui 56% ne veulent pas
donner une majorité au président réélu
les mêmes français qui disait qu'il ne
voulait pas d'un match retour mâcon le
pen et qu'on place et emmanuel macron
humaine le pen en tête de tous les de
tous les candidats la fille de jean luc
mélenchon je n'avais que ça à la fois un
coup de bluff et un coup de génie un
coup de bluff parce que au sens propre
du terme cette affiche n'a pas de sens
on n'a pas élire un premier ministre on
va élire des députés qui vont former une
majorité
est en fonction la couleur de la
majorité le président république nommera
un premier ministre dont il pense qu'il
pourra obtenir la confiance de cette
assemblée donc voilà mais c'est que lui
qui veut instaurer une 6ème république
ils jouent à fond la logique de la 5e à
savoir la cinquième ville c'est le
pouvoir incarné le pouvoir personnaliser
et un moment on voit bien que toutes les
eaux toutes les oppositions au pluriel
qu'elle soit l air qu elles soient
rarement nationale qu'elle soit même le
reste de la gauche essaie d'exister bon
lui il préempte pas ce que dira et les
émois premier ministre cela veut dire
l'opposition emmanuel macron c'est moi
et si doit quoi bon
dans l'imaginaire ou alors est
éduqué il installe dans l'idée des
électeurs notamment aux acteurs de
gauche on peut gagner la gauche peut
gagner regarde au premier tour j'ai pas
été loin de me qualifier cette fois ci
en plus avec le ressentiment contre
macron lui-même etc on peut gagner et
dire premier ministre il s'installe dans
un post casse une légimité forte pour
dire voyez cette hypothèse devient
crédible il utilise des mots qui rendent
crédible une hypothèse qui sur le plan
électoral est pour le moins très
incertaine ok c'est très clair alors on
va regarder ce sujet très pédagogique
pour tout comprendre de ce scrutin on
est à la chaîne parlementaire il faut
atteindre 12 et demi pour cent des
inscrits est pas
et suffrages exprimés pour se qualifier
ça fait toute la différence
législativement d'emplois ces signes
hélène bonduelle regarder
pour être élu dès le premier tour le
dimanche 12 juin un candidat doit
obtenir la majorité absolue c'est à dire
plus de 50% des suffrages exprimés et un
nombre de voix au moins égal à 25% des
électeurs inscrits sur les listes
électorales
un seuil inaccessible en cas de forte
abstention qui peut empêcher un candidat
même en tête de l'emporter dès le
premier tour
rappelons qu'il ya cinq ans plus de 50 %
des électeurs s'étaient abstenus au
premier tour si aucun candidat n'a
atteint la majorité absolue ou recueilli
25% des voix des électeurs inscrits
alors un second tour est organisé
il aura lieu le 19 juin pour accéder à
ce second tour en théorie il faut
obtenir un nombre de voix au moins égal
à 12 et demi pour cent des électeurs
inscrits mais si un seul candidat a
atteint ce seuil la règle permet au
deuxième de se maintenir et si jamais
aucun candidat ne parvient au plancher
alors les deux premiers sont autorisés à
y participer ces contraintes rendent les
triangulaires et les quadrangulaire de
plus en plus rares dans ce scrutin à
l'issue du second tour le candidat
arrivé en tête est élu mais en cas
d'égalité c'est le plus âgé qui
l'emportent
enfin une fois élu pour espérer peser
dans les débats législatifs
le député doit faire partie d'un groupe
parlementaire et pour exister un groupe
doit réunir au moins 15 députés
pascal perrineau avec ces règles là il
ya un maître mot dans l'élection c'est
alliance dès le premier tour cette
alliance parce que en effet étant donné
le fort taux d'abstention
des forces qui n'atteindraient pas 12 5%
des inscrits sont condamnés à témoigner
dans un premier tour et puis ensuite à
disparaître puisqu'au fond on l'avait
déjà vu en 2017 les second tour où il y
avait des triangulaires ou deco attendu
l'air ça n'existe presque plus donc plus
personne ne peut être véritablement élus
en faisant par exemple je ne sais pas
moi 30 30 % dans une quadrangulaire
voilà donc
les deux candidats ou candidates qui
qu'on le retrouve au second tour ce qui
sera la loi dans l'immense majorité des
circonscriptions ils doivent avoir
derrière eux en effet une alliance alors
une alliance ou bien avant le premier
tour et la plupart du temps une alliance
entre les deux tours où la jouer bien ou
bien une alliance par exemple et de
gauche plurielle mais de quelle gauche
plurielle s'agira-t-il parce que quand
on parle d'union de la gauche de gauche
plurielle attendait ça ne comprenait pas
la gauche de la gauche l'extrême gauche
jusqu'à maintenant donc là il s'agit
derrière l'aimable visage de mêlant
chant il s'agit d'imposer une nouvelle
conception de la gauche qui irait
jusqu'à la gauche de la gauche
éventuellement même aux forces de de
l'extrême gauche mais une réunion
stratégique de ma ronde
ça suscite de très nombreux débats chez
les écologistes
chez les socialistes qui ne sont pas
habitués à cette union de la gauche là
et qui se disent dans une union de la
gauche de ce type nous allons être avalé
parce que l'union de la gauche entre
quelqu'un qui fait plus de 20% des
suffrages exprimés et ceux qui viennent
de faire moins de 2 % des suffrages
exprimés on voit très bien comment ça se
termine évidemment le rapport de force
n'est pas le même un mot peut-être sur
la droite de la droite l'extrême droite
on va dire
là on sent que il ya quand même des
fissures qui peuvent qui peuvent jouer
est ce que marine le pen peut se
permettre de claquer la porte à
reconquête d'eric zemmour ou pas en tout
cas je pense qu'il en a clairement
l'attention elle a déjà fait plaisir à
voir elle est face à un premier problème
c'est que traduit finalement
elle parvient à faire des scores élevés
et par deux fois qu'ils ont qualifié
pour le second tour à la présidentielle
mais ne parvient pas à garder ce capital
aux élections législatives la dernière
fois elle fait 21% premier tour elle est
au second tour et un mois et demi à
peine après le front national à l'époque
oui qui s'appelait encore front national
je pense fait 13,2 pour cent briller sur
le dans le même élan de pascal tout à
fait raison de dire que les créatifs son
élection de confirmation mais
précisément pour le vainqueur et n a pas
réussi à retrouver sa donc ainsi un
premier problème est ce que ayant
franchi un seuil supplémentaire elle
pourra combler cet écart c'est une
première question ensuite il va sur la
question de l'aide de phase ii de
l'entente de l'accord de l'alliance avec
eric zemmour seringue à quelque chose de
paradoxal on a entendu louis aliot à
l'instant et sur ce point ne peut que
lui donner raison eric zemmour a tout
construit pour dire non au pénal et nul
ne peut pas gagner celle qui nous fait
perdre depuis depuis vingt ans la
famille le pen en est à sa huitième
défaite consécutive comme il l'a répété
dimanche soir ça paraît pas que celle de
dire bambins ccc gros naze maintenant je
m'allie avec eux est ce que est ce que
c'est possible que reconquête fasse
perdre des circonscriptions à marine le
pen on sait où on va voir la carte tiens
on a vu on a regardé les résultats du
premier tour on voit que le
rassemblement national voilà il est très
fort est arrivé en tête au premier tour
à la présidentielle entend tout le nord
et l'est du pays une petite partie du
centre et puis tout le sud est là est ce
qu'on peut imaginer qu'elle peut
performer sans alliance avec reconquête
oui elle peut bien évidemment faire ce
que c'est pas de bon sens des
socialistes là c'est certain c'est plus
important alors il faudra quand même
voir ce que donnerait reconquête en
force indépendante aux législatives sans
doute moins que ce 7% mais
incontestablement les stratégie d'union
elles sont essentielles et vitales même
à gauche elles le sont aussi du côté de
la droite radicale si on regarde les
résultats au niveau des circonscriptions
le rassemblement national seul dans un
contexte de participation similaire à
celui du
2017 il pourrait se maintenir dans à peu
près la moitié des circonscriptions avec
l'adjonction des voix de reconquête donc
de ses 7 % de dérégler mots on passe à
420 circonscription on voit que c'est
c'est énorme c'est 7% s'il se
matérialise ils sont énormes mais la
question c'est de savoir si la campagne
va leur permettre de se matérialiser ou
si quoi qui conseillent d'ores et déjà
qu'il sera pas candidat eric zemmour
vous confirmez guillaume tabard je
confirme ça ça lui qu'il faut demander
mais ils ont jugé crucial il faut donc
comprendre que lui et marion maréchal
finalement non plus et apparemment non
plus oui mais se dit bon là on y touche
les dividendes plutôt il ils ont empoché
les pertes de cette division parce que
on a vu notamment que dans la région
paca en
reconquête eric zemmour a été
relativement fort par rapport à soi
nationale là où le fn est fort bon mais
sauf que cercle dans le vaucluse le rn
et reconquête sont forts on en est là
c'est le cas type ou s'ils se
maintiennent tous les deux bah ça au
lieu d'avoir un fort qui peut gagner on
a deux moyens qui peuvent faire tous les
deux et puis l équation la droite alors
on y vient stéphane l'équation possible
ou impossible c'est la question vous
étiez au comité stratégique des
républicains ce matin alors on comprend
que l'enjeu il est absolument vital pour
pour le parti menacé d'extinction quelle
est exactement la stratégie retenue ce
matin alors après la déroute électorale
les élèves ont décidé de clamer leur
indépendance pour les législatives comme
après le premier tour la droite a donc
dit qu'elles n'étaient ni fongible dans
le maquereau nice mais dans le pénis
nicolas sarkozy lui-même avait appelé au
rassemblement derrière le président
réélu ce n'est pas la ligne des
républicains il n'y aura donc pas
d'alliance pas de coalition avec
emmanuel macron écouter les candidats
les républicains n'auront qu'une seule
étiquette la droite et le centre et
n'auront pas de label majorité
présidentielle parce que nous ne ferons
pas dans cette majorité présidentielle
dont nous ne voulons pas du projet et
dont nous avons notre différence donc on
comprend mais un ace et / ou pas c'est
la ligne définitive des républicains pas
d'alliance alors c'est sûr elle a été
définie ce matin par conseil stratégique
du parti qui regroupe une vingtaine de
figures des républicains c'est
l'équivalent du gouvernement du parti
mais la question c'est est ce que tout
le monde ait un partage combien de temps
ça va tenir parce que ce matin dès ce
matin on entendu des gens contesté la
méthode certains disent il ne fallait
pas prendre cette décision en comité
politique comme en comité stratégique
pardon comme sébastien hui le député du
nord lui il aurait voulu un bureau
politique là il ya 130 personnes autour
de la table qui votent pour ou contre la
ligne gaël perdriau le maire
saint-etienne avait déjà appelé lui à un
conseil national extraordinaire dont il
ya un problème sur la méthode pour
certains députés évidemment et certains
élus à l'est républicain ceux qui sont
les plus n'est plus apte les plus les
plus enclins à soutenir emmanuel macron
et puis sur le fond ce matin concept
stratégique deux personnes se sont
abstenues n'ont pas voulu voter cette
ligne c'était philippe juvin qui dès son
arrivée au conseil stratégique a dit non
et il a affiché la couleur
pour les gouverner avec les manières
mâcon
gouverner avec emmanuel macron moi je
veux que les partis de gouvernement
travaille ensemble
lui il voulait plutôt une ligne prônons
le rassemblement mais l'autre personne
qui s'est abstenu ce matin mais ces
derniers abad le patron des veuves
scellerait poids moyen avec les classes
et un poids beaucoup plus important lui
aussi il défend nine plus ouvert sa
emmanuel macron et surtout plus étanche
avec le rassemblement national beaucoup
soupçonnent d'ailleurs de vouloir
rallier les marcheurs ont dû revenir je
vais être allé voir l'année dernière il
aurait les rendez-vous avec thierry
solère qui est le conseiller politique
des manuels macro est ce que vous la
comprenez stratégiquement cette cette
ligne pascal perrineau est ce qu'elle
est intelligente politiquement oui je
crois si vous voulez qu'un ralliement
après avoir cultivé sa différence dans
un temps très court c'est le meilleur
moyen de devenir complètement illisible
ce qui ne veut pas dire que l es ils
sont déjà un peu voilà ils le sont déjà
suffisamment mais c'est le premier
groupe d'opposition 101 députés je veux
dire ce maul extrêmement important ils
doivent le défendent ils doivent faire
je sais pas si vous parlez de résistance
veut faire attention aux mots qu'on
utilise en tout cas de résilience il
faut qu'ils montrent qu'ils sont
résilients parce que c'est encore une
grande force sur le terrain antoine à
savoir combien tournée était
forcément ils ont
bien sûr quoi former un groupe
parlementaire un problème bien au delà à
mon avis mais le problème c'est il faut
écouter christian jacob attentivement
quand vous écoutez le patron de l air il
dit en effet il rejette sur son centre
gauche pour lui l hérault m haies et
horizons l'allié des lèvres m il rejette
de manière claire et ça c'est une
continuité et ça met fin à des fantasmes
toute alliance avec la droite de la
droite reconquête et le rassemblement
national et il dit nous pratiquerons une
opposition intelligente c'est à dire une
opposition nous ne priverons pas de
voter des projets de loi des
propositions qui nous semble aller dans
le bon sens tel que nous le définissons
nous mêmes donc il y a tout de même va
permettre dès mardi une différence d
ouverture bien sûr ça permet surtout
d'essayer de garder ses reçus le
politique est intact avant les
législatives et en effet il a fait
signal parce que c'est beaucoup disent
c'est aussi sur le fond j'avais un
député de l'eure qui me disent mais
valérie pécresse disait qu emmanuel
macron avec photocopie et son programme
mais en fait c'est vrai donc moi sur le
fond qu'est ce que je fais est ce que
est ce que je reste sur une ligne 13 ans
d'opposition ou est-ce que je reste sur
une ligne plus conciliante on a beaucoup
tangué vous pensez game tabac ils vont
regarder sur le terrain dans leurs
circonscriptions les résultats celui qui
en tête 6 et macron il va être tenté de
partir chez par la majorité prennent
leur ai annoncé que je pense que le seul
critère putté
et l'air sortant ça n'est pas la motion
votée au comité stratégique ce ne sera
pas les consignes de puissants jacob
c'est qu'est ce qui se passe chez moi
sur les 100 une séance cription
j'ai refait le calcul mère j'ai pu les
chiffres mais je crois qu'on a à peu
près 60 ou emmanuel macron est arrivé en
tête et 40 ou
où marine le pen est arrivé en tête mais
on peut en tirer de conclusions
différentes un député et l'air là où
marine le pen est très forte peut dire
mais faut justement que je n'ai pas de
marcheurs contre moi parce que contre
marine le pen je pourrais avoir une
sorte de front républicain qui va jouer
raconte le candidat est reine je peux
avoir un fond est plus qu'un qui est qui
qui va me ce qui va me sauver wip
inversement se dire là j'ai beaucoup de
lecteurs et rennes donc faut plutôt que
j'allais courir à droite vous voyez et
les on voit par damien abad qui tentent
d'allécher mais elle macron dans l'ain
l'un est un département où le fn est
très fort pour lui en tire cette
conclusion cette conclusion là après
chacun joue un peu si j'ose dire mais je
pense que le verre n'est pas n'est pas
galvaudé à durcir la position des autres
pour justifier sa propre sa propre
attitude on entendu beaucoup la ra p10
mais nous on ne veut plus de cette
opposition systématique
bon on veut une position intelligente
c'est à bon très bien mais depuis 2007
dans le parti du temps 8 est dirigée par
laurent wauquiez niveau national et par
christian jacob à l'assemblée le groupe
ait l'air à voter 50% dès textes
présentés par le gouvernement
n'oublions pas que les trois quarts du
groupe l air se sont abstenus sur le
vote de confiance à douar film dont on
dit qu'il est le le critère du o2
d'appartenir à la majorité ou
d'opposition qu'est ce que ça veut dire
selon vous c'est qu'à la fin une fine et
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
l'extinction c'est l'absorption parce
que au niveau programmatique qui aura
plus assez de jeu pour annoncer que la
droite à une question que l'on joué
quelque chose en 2027 elle a une
question de long terme est une question
de court terme et le malheureusement la
question de crotone va l'empêcher de
poser question de long terme la question
de long terme c'est s'interroger en
profondeur sur ce qu'est la droite et
sur ce que sont les droits à terre qu'il
faut s'interroger clairement sur en gros
est ce que le maquereau nisme est ou non
une nouvelle forme de la droite mais il
faut aussi s'interroger sur quelle est
la nature de cette droite qui est à la
droite de lr aujourd'hui sérieuse de
l'électeur qui vote marine le pen ou qui
votent leur exil bourse une fois qu'on a
répété en boucle il ya une digue
infranchissable d'abord les électeurs
eux de la voix pas la digue bon bon mais
ça il ya bien un moment où emma quand
même mal macro montrer lui-même qu' il
fallait parfois faire sauter les
frontières pour composer quelque chose
de nouveau est temps que
lr et pression' est une sorte de nini
mais le ni-ni il ne satisfait que ce
guide une fois qu'on a dit ça très bien
mais le nid le ni-ni y conduit à ce que
au fil des années le le saucisson alex
aurait été guillaume tabard ce soir
inventer vous
rénovez vous dépassez vous comme p
manuel macron comment comment mathieu
gallet les électeurs regarde au fond ce
qui arrive aux aux républicains alors ça
dépend des circonscriptions mais aux
législatives il en reste des électeurs
qui pourraient voilà voté pour pour
leurs députés de manière plus local
voilà une des forces qui reste aux
républicains c'est quand même d'avoir
effectivement un ancrage local avec un
certain nombre de députés qui sont bien
connus dans leur circonscription dont le
travail est apprécié et qui grâce à sa
peuvent effectivement espérer aller au
second tour et être réélu et sans doute
je suis d'accord former un groupe
parlementaire d'ailleurs nettement plus
qu'un groupe parlementaire si le divan
de manière indépendante mais on voit
effectivement que le parti est vraiment
pris en étau entre ces trois pôles
idéologique qui se dessine et qui sont
claires cohérent on comprend la france
que veut marine le pen que veut emmanuel
macron que je jean luc mélenchon c'est
le dlr c'est beaucoup moins clair les
partis qui sont pris en interstices dans
l'interstice de ces blocs que ce soit
les républicains que ce soit le parti
socialiste sont dans des situations
idéologique très difficile et du coup
rencontrent des problèmes avec leur
électorat à maud conclusion oui une
toute petite terminer ces débats reveco
cabano les électeurs de droite on prend
les électeurs qui avaient voté fillon en
2017 sont allés voter à la
présidentielle en effet ce n'est qu' un
gros tiers qui à voter pour leur
candidate et ils ont été attirés par les
aimants les deux aimants macron le pen
là dans une transcription résumera et là
dans les circonscriptions ça va être
différent pour un électeur et l'air pour
un électeur de droite modérée aller
voter pour l'obscur candidat du r'n
voyez où
l'obscur
n'a pas réussi à s'implanter là on va
voir les brebis égarées revenir
partiellement aubert kessel et député
sortant dans bien compris là ils sont en
campagne à fond dans leur circuit
certains me disent je veux plus entendre
parler du national je fais ma compagne
je revois le terrain visage pour une
personnalité donc moi je passe tout mon
temps sur le terrain et laissez moi
tranquille avec le national est bien
merci législatives ne sont pas les
présidentielles c'est un des
enseignements de ce débat sur lcp
évidemment on ne fait que commencer a
déplié problématiques après
problématique fait cette élection les
enjeux de ce scrutin merci infiniment on
va à présent accueillir notre grand
témoin il est essayiste romancier ancien
conseiller de matteo renzi le président
le think tank italien volta et il vient
de publier un roman haletant d'une
incroyable actualité le mage du kremlin
chez gallimard où la folle histoire de
vladislav sourkov conseiller politique
de l'ombre du chef du kremlin c'est un
peu le roman vrai du système poutine on
a plein de questions à poser à giuliano
d'armes poli comme les skis ce sujet de
marco pognon
si on vous invite giuliano da empoli
c'est pour se plonger dans les arcanes
du pouvoir russe avec vous nous voulons
entrer dans la tête de vladimir poutine
car il ya 62 jours déjà le maître du
kremlin déclarer la guerre en ukraine
j'ai décidé de mener une opération
militaire spéciale nous ferons tout pour
des nazis fier est démilitarisé
l'ukraine juliano da empoli vous êtes
écrivain ancien conseiller politique de
matteo renzi mais aussi président de
volta un laboratoire d'idées dans votre
dernier livre roman qui s'inspire de
personnages et de situations réelles
vous retracer l'énigmatique trajectoire
de celui qu'on appelait le mage du
kremlin un certain vladislav surkov
d'abord metteur en scène puis producteur
d'émissions de télé réalité qu'il
deviendra en 1999 l'éminence grise de
vladimir poutine
le raspoutine du nouveau de ça ce
personnage là et a été sans talent dans
l'édification du système de pouvoir de
poutine parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a
importé en politique la logique de
théâtre d'avant-garde est un théâtre
politique qu'il a créée d'abord en
russie et après projetté sûr sûr sûr le
reste du monde sourkov le spin doctor de
vladimir poutine aujourd'hui déchu
assignés à résidence
lui qui a pourtant contribué à
l'ascension et à la consolidation du
pouvoir poutinien car le concept de la
verticalité du pouvoir s'est lui déguisé
une dictature en démocratie c'est lui
mettre en place les méthodes de
désinformation c'est encore et toujours
lui un effroyable trompe l'oeil pour
mieux imposer d'après vous la stratégie
du fid de faire autrement dit faire
régner le chaos si vous voulez casser un
fil de fer font le tordre d'un côté et
puis de l'autre la propagande russe ce
n'est pas que pousser des pro russes ou
des traditionalistes dans le monde on va
pousser pas que les suprématistes blancs
on va pousser les des super bock et les
mouvements lgbt les plus radicaux on n'a
pas poussé que les climatosceptiques on
va pousser les collabos loeb aussi et on
va créer du conflit le plus possible
partout et alors que la guerre en
ukraine se déchaînent plusieurs
questions ce soir la stratégie du chaos
va-t-elle nous mener à la troisième
guerre mondiale ce fameux surkov at il
joué un rôle dans le conflit russo
ukrainien
et puis comment interpréter la série de
disparitions et d'assassinats qui frappe
les oligarques russes nous attendons vos
réponses à coup sûr passionnante
bonsoir du llano d'empoli et merci
beaucoup d'être là on va revenir sur un
certain nombre de ces questions mais
d'abord tout simplement comment au fond
vous avez rencontré en tout cas dans le
récit mais comment vous est venue l'idée
d'écrire sur sourkov celui que vous
appelez vadim barabanov dans le roman
bages et j'ai écrit avant celui ci un
autre livre qui s'appelait les
ingénieurs du chaos et qui était
consacrée aux au spin doctor nationaux
populistes
donc ces figures un peu dans l'ombre qui
travaille aux côtés de leaders comme
orban matteo salvini ou donald trump et
que j'avais un peu décrits dans ce livre
est dans la dans les recherches pour ce
livre je me suis à un certain moment
j'ai rencontré ce personnage assez
extraordinaire qui s'appelle justement à
vladislav surkov est que vous venez un
peu d'introduire et c'est une découverte
qui m'a tout de suite beaucoup frappé
c'est à dire j'ai pensé d'abord
l'inclure dans le livre et puis la
dimension romanesque de son histoire et
de son personnage a un peu pris le
dessus alors justement racontez nous
cette vie absolument fascinante sourkov
metteur en scène sourkov passionné de
théâtre
/ d'avant-garde producteurs aussi
d'émissions de télé réalité qui est il
oui surkov bon après encore une fois il
faut absolument souligner la la la
différence entre le personnage de monde
m'ont vraiment balanov et sourkov parce
que dans mon roman je lui attribue une
histoire familiale et une vie privée qui
n'ont rien à voir avec avec la sienne
mais c'est aussi extrêmement documenté
vous avez enquêté en russie ah oui clair
il ya tous les faire rassembler mais les
dialogues les personnages dans leur
intimité là c'est inventer tous les
faits politiques historiques sont réels
et même une bonne partie des noms des
personnages donc non seulement poutine
mais l'entourage de poutine et là en son
vrai nom mais le personnage principal
par contre est un personnage composite
parce que c'est pour ça aussi que je
n'ai pas fait un essai de sujets un peu
tenté par par une biographie de souk off
mais après j'ai quand même
là j'aurais dû peut-être leur encontre
et essayer de et du coup j'ai préféré un
peu l'inventer donc l'être aussi dans la
tête de me mettre dans cet art et 2 et
du coup on sait que c'est un peu la
seule façon de le faire si vous voulez à
partir de beaucoup de recherches en
effet parce que j'ai j'ai préparé le
livre un peu comme s'il s'agissait d'un
essai j'ai rencontré des gens j'ai
voyagé à moscou j'ai discuté avec pas
mal de monde y compris des gens qui
fréquentent qui connaissent surkov alors
justement la logique du théâtre c'est
intéressant d'avant-garde wiki la porte
d'une certaine façon dans la question du
pouvoir politique oui comme vous le
disiez c'est quelqu'un qui a un spectre
culturel très vaste au contraire de la
majorité des conseillers des proches de
poutine qui sont quand même un peu plus
gris un peu plus prévisible et donc on a
l'impression à plusieurs reprises que
c'est quelqu'un qui va interpréter un
peu son métier de stratège et de
communicants de poutine comme comme une
sorte de performance artistique donc il
va faire créer tous eu ce théâtre de de
frais de faut de vraies personnes en
fait c'est un maître de la manipulation
et crée sa réalité exactement il crée sa
propre réalité
il sa propre réalité on pourrait appeler
ça une sorte de deux filles démocratie
où ce n'est pas que le moment du vote
par exemple qui est falsifiée mais tout
le processus est falsifiée parce qu'en
réalité les principaux personnages et
leaders qui sont sur le théâtre
politique vous ne savez jamais selon la
méthode surkov si c'est véritablement
des opposants de poutine du régime ou si
ce sont des gens qui sont manipulés
utilisé par louis finance et créé de
toutes pièces comme certains mouvements
certains partis et certains leaders et
il est le fait que vous ne le sachiez
pas donc la révélation de la
manipulation fait partie de la mission
croyable ça rend folle une société c'est
à la désoriente il crée des parties
soutien audard s'est lui contenté d'un
footing il crée des partis d'opposition
y révèle que en fait c'est des partis
qui n'existe pas vraiment mais la
société totalement déstabilisé après oui
parce que et c'est ce qu'on ne comprend
pas toujours de là d'ailleurs de la
propagande de russe en général
l'objectif n'est pas nécessairement de
convaincre ou de faire croire qu un
square que ce soit vrai mais l'objectif
c'est de multiplier les versions
désorienté et donc à la fin de créer un
sens de comme ça un peu de passivité de
baptiser voilà et d'appétit qui sera du
coup ou favorable pour des opérations
politiques même très dur alors il
commence à travailler avec poutine en
1999 un moment où poutine n'est pas du
tout populaire il ya un événement
particulier racontez-nous il ya des
attentats dont on ne sait d'ailleurs pas
s'ils sont véritablement commis par ceux
à qui on les attribue des de cette
chaîne c'est un déclic c'est un déclic
en 99 poutine est le cinquième premier
ministre en deux ans il est impopulaire
comme les autres personnes ne le connais
même plus on ne connaît plus les noms
des différents premier ministre mais il
a d'abord une origine différente par
rapport par rapport aux autres parce que
ce n'est pas un homme politique mais
c'est quelqu'un qui vient du kgb donc il
à ce que le grand inquisiteur de dossier
et ce qu'ils appelleraient le mystère
kahn des ingrédients du pouvoir et
l'autre ingrédient du pouvoir pour le
grand inquisiteur de dostoïevski seul
miracle lots miracle sous formes
tragiques il arrive pour poutine en 99
quand comme vous le disiez au mois de
septembre des tours d'immeubles commence
d'habitation ordinaire commence à
s'écrouler dans la banlieue de moscou la
nuit en plus quand les gens dorment en
faisant des centaines de victimes issa
dans une société qui est déjà très
déstabilisée où il ya eu une phase et
l'argent roi des gars c est la honte des
années tout net si nos six exactement
telle demande
l'humiliation internationale
nationale c'est l'état qui n'arrivent
plus à payer les salaires c'est le
rouble qui qui qui qui fait défaut et
c'est
également d'ordre et corps les immeubles
s'écroulent évidemment c'est la panique
complète et là il ya un homme qui réagit
immédiatement avec une dureté inouïe
donc il va avoir cette phrase un peu
vulgaire mais qui va marquer l'époque où
il va dire nous poursuivrons les
terroristes jusque dans les chiottes si
c'est là qu'il ce qu'il se cache sa
marque les esprits mais surtout il va le
faire de façon très très violente parce
que il va bon on connaît l'histoire il
va raser de gosselies il va faire la
guerre en tchétchénie d'une façon
extraordinairement brutale et fait
advenir 7 verticale du pouvoir cette
stratégie du chaos c'est lui d'une
certaine façon qui qu'il invente et vous
raconter très bien aussi le regard
qu'ils portent sur les occidentaux que
nous sommes c'est à dire voilà fondée
sur la raison essayons de minimiser les
incertitudes alors que la société russe
comment dire à une intimité avec le
chaos et ça il le comprend et
l'accentuer oui je crois que bon d'abord
après c'est peut-être ma projection de
lui même est
il il ne respecte pas beaucoup notre
façon de faire de la politique ou c'est
justement des gens comme ça qui vont se
confronter avec des slides powerpoint et
statistiques des courbes de croissance
économique ou doudou de point de détail
alors que poutine on voit bien que la
politique c'est vraiment une question de
vie et de mort c'est une question de il
utilise très peu des demos d'ailleurs
statistiques ou technique c'est toujours
des questions d'honneur de valeur d
un peu mythique de la construction du
pouvoir de poutine de long on a mis tant
de temps à comprendre
poutine et on l'a vu au moment de
l'invasion de l'ukraine personne n'y
croyait quels types d' aveuglement
on a fait preuve on a été victime d'une
forme de déni sur sa réalité a dit oui
mais c'est d'ailleurs le cas de la chine
est pas ne n'est pas le soleil on a eu
des aveuglements par rapport à la chine
et dans des contextes différents et des
rapports différents mais je crois c'est
parce qu'en effet nous sommes dans une
dans une logique qui est la logique à
travers laquelle par exemple c'est s'est
faite la construction européenne qui est
une logique que je sois surtout
juridique
d'accord formel des changes d'ouverture
où on pense que les conflits seront
réglés à travers les changes de commerce
et où la dimension économique de toute
façon fait fait prime un peu sur ce sur
tout et vous diriez qu'on a jamais pris
la mesure de la menace parce qu'on
connaît les canaux de de propagande la
déstabilisation par la cyberattaque la
désinformation le complotisme la manière
dont aussi les milieux politiques
culturels sont infiltrés on le voit
d'ailleurs en france 1 avec marine le
pen et non bon nombre d'élus pourquoi on
a l'impression de ne pas avoir pris
confiance avant cette guerre je crois
qu'on ne peut que nous n'avons pas pris
conscience de la dimension
20e siècle et même et même peut-être
précédente très primaire de quelqu'un
qui va faire des combinés campagne de
désinformation et de propagande
sophistiqué d'ailleurs donc mais qui au
fond va vouloir reconquérir un certain
nombre kilomètres carrés de territoire
ce qui pour nous est inconcevable de
quelqu'un qui va faire appel aux au sang
et eau et aux racines historiques
d'ailleurs les falsifiant assez assez
largement tout ça pour nous j'ai un
passage dans le livre je parle de notre
rapport
à l'uniforme dans l'uniforme militaire
pour nous mêmes même la cravate
aujourd'hui est devenu un peu le signe
comme ça comme ça de quelqu'un qui est
très clair c'est un peu étriqué là alors
imaginons l'uniforme militaire ça
n'existe plus là vraiment poutine est
dès le début dans un autre monde mais le
problème c'est qu'il entend aujourd'hui
de nous faire basculer tous dans son
monde justement vous dites que c'est sûr
qu'au fc le code source des populismes
ça veut dire qu'il a essaimé cette
stratégie du chaos a essaimé on pense à
style banane à beppe grillo en italie
matteo salvini oui je crois après ça ne
s'est pas fait de façon mécanique
évidemment cd mais je pense que ça a été
le le premier surkov du coup vous parlez
du chaos cette stratégie du chaos que la
outsiders enfin disons le le personnage
le plus faible parce que ne faut pas
oublier quand même que la russie est
faible de l'économie économique et ses
challengers dont vous parliez au début
il était aussi marginaux par rapport aux
systèmes et il a l'idée de créer le
maximum de chaos qui d'ailleurs est
parfaitement compatible avec le
fonctionnement des réseaux sociaux et de
la machine des algorithmes qui vont
primer qui ne vont pas tellement pris
mais la cohérence d'un programme ou d'un
discours mais vont pas opprimer les
coups d'éclat permanent voilà ça c'est
une machine que que sourkov a je crois
de développer parmi les premiers tout
cas c'est absolument passionnant c'est
un roman le roman vrai du poutinisme on
pourrait dire le match du kremlin c'est
chez gallimard et je vous le recommande
chaudement vous ne l'avez pas rencontré
d'ailleurs il a doc est donné qu'une
seule interview surkov c'était au
financial times et il avait cette phrase
une surdose de liberté est mortel pour
un état tout était déjà dit vous rester
avec moi parce que c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos a franchi pour leur
parti pris ce soir jean rémi baudot va
nous éclairer sur le calendrier très
très politique des semaines à venir pour
emmanuel macron fanny guinochet pour
l'économie veillée d'armes des syndicats
avant le défilé du 1er mai puis delphine
sabattier va nous raconter les coulisses
d'une mainmise celle du milliardaire
elon musk sur le géant twitter nous
affranchit les voici bonsoir à tous les
trois ravi de vous retrouver les
affranchis qui commence par la politique
jean rémy on a vu des différentes
manoeuvres aux législatives dans notre
débat tout à l'heure mais l'agenda de
l'exécutif et celui du président en
particulier est aussi très très chargé
oui et j'aimerais commencer par une
photo la photo de l'actuel gouvernement
car fait assez rare se sont tous les
ministres qui sont convoqués au grand
complet jeudi à l'elysée à l'occasion du
conseil des ministres tout le
gouvernement d'un coup tiens tiens
peut-être un indice qu'il s'agit là du
dernier conseil des ministres pour cette
formation probable remaniement attendu
la semaine prochaine sauf que pour
remanier et bien il faut savoir manier
les équilibres d'une éventuelle nouvelle
majorité les susceptibilités interne et
surtout les messages politiques on doit
pas se lancer ici dans le temps les
prédictions des listes inutile de
ministrable il y en a déjà plein d'après
la presse mais je vous partage la
réflexion d'un important ministre
concernant le futur remaniement il faut
trois ou quatre forces politiques et un
ou deux symboles voilà je laisse chacun
méditer
alors être qu'on a la certitude que jean
castex va quitter matignon c'est
peut-être la seule certitude il a
d'ailleurs déjà annoncé qu'il remettrait
sa démission au gouvernement autre
certitude des prochains jours il y a
demain mercredi l'hommage national aux
invalides du président macron donc au
comédien michel bouquet il ya aussi un
déplacement des manuels macron à berlin
dans la foulée de son intronisation use
de sa as réinvestiture officiel et puis
autre certitude et bien c'est le début
des emmerdes pour emmanuel macron début
des emmerdes troisième tour social oui
le plus dur commençait ce qui il aurait
dit à l'annoncé des résultats dimanche
dernier à 20 heures il faut dire que
tous les voyants sont au rouge avec une
bonne dose de remise en question de nos
institutions quand certains dissertent
sur la légitimité et la représentativité
du chef de l'état en mélangeant tous les
chiffres l'atmosphère est à la tension
politique emmanuel macron a très peu de
chance de connaître un état de grâce ses
projets de retraite ont déjà braqué une
partie des oppositions et des
partenaires sociaux on pourra en parler
dans un instant avec l'acteur ni ses
promesses sur le climat ont laissé de
marbre les écologistes et les manoeuvres
et ses manoeuvres risque de ne pas être
payante politiquement il peut nommer un
premier ministre de gauche il ou elle ne
sera jamais assez à gauche pour les
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon donc oui
à l'agenda il risque d'y avoir de la
contestation reste donc à être efficace
la lutte contre l'inflation les
carburants cher là la guerre en ukraine
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
l'insécurité la proportionnelle la
modernisation de nos institutions et en
écrivant cette liste et on vous lisez
dans vous lisant cette liste je me dis
que la tambouille politique c'est
peut-être quand même beaucoup plus
simple que de résoudre concrètement les
problèmes des français souvent vous
allez vous regarder de près la situation
politique française ah oui tout à fait
les fascinante parce qu'on voit bien
qu'on entre dans un monde nouveau bon le
président a été élu mais au-delà de tout
ça tout est décomposé et tout est à
reconstruire donc à peine élu on sent
déjà le chemin de croix pas d'état de
grâce même parfois quelqu'un souvent les
ministres par le quinquennat de colère
après celui là
c'est tout un programme oui je sens ça
mais très familier en tant qu'italien je
connais un peu ce scénario là mais c'est
frappant de retrouver en france cette
dimension de l'état de la monocoque
exactement je pense que nous avons
commencé bien avant vous mais vous êtes
en train de faire des progrès rapides et
ça vous a surpris que marine le pen
malgré ses liens avec le régime russe ne
les ai pas vraiment payé elle fait 13
millions de voix dans le pays oui je
dois dire ça m'a très surpris heureux
surtout au début que tout que tout était
concentré disant sûr sur la figure de
zemmour et qu'il ait réussi à ne presque
pas payer alors que en argent politique
l'argent ce n'est pas anecdotique d'où
vient l'argent ça ça compte et donc le
fait que l'argent de du parti de marine
le pen viennent de moscou s'était quand
même c'était quand même un petit détail
alors on enchaîne avec vous faites ni
troisième tour social on en parlait à
l'instant les syndicats lancent un
sérieux investissement avertissement à
emmanuel macron pour le pour le premier
mais il voyait alors faire avec eux
passent exactement il n'ya qu'à lire la
tribune que signe laurent b cet après
midi dans le journal le monde pour
comprendre la mise en garde avec des
mots assez ferme laurent berger dit à
emmanuel macron vous devrez faire avec
nous vous ne pourrez pas faire tout tout
seul relever tous ces défis vous ne
pourrez pas nous méprisent et il faut
nous écouter davantage il répète
d'ailleurs seulement ce mot sans quoi
votre exercice du pouvoir sera bloquée
sans quoi vous ne pourrez pas gouverner
sous-entendu ça sera la rue qui prendra
le dessus et le message est extrêmement
exigeant et laurent berger d'habitude et
donc le patron de la cfdt un
syndicaliste plutôt conciliant ou en
tout cas bienveillant avec vous c'est
d'ailleurs c'était le slogan la fiche de
campagne
entendre de ce message il est il est
partagé par la cgt force ouvrière oui
tous les syndicats mettent en garde
alors c'est vrai qu'ils ont le sentiment
d'avoir joué le jeu entre les deux tours
souvent ils ont appelé à faire barrage
contre marine le pen et pour autant le
programme d' emmanuel macron assez
simple il le rejette en bloc le
programme en tout cas économique et
sociale que ce soit la réforme des
retraites décaler l'âge à 64 ans aucun
des syndicats n'en veut la réforme de
l'assurance chômage ils ne veulent pas
en entendre parler pareil pour la
réforme du rsa ou emmanuel macron en
tout cas demanderait aux allocataires en
échange du rsa aux bénéficiaires de
faire un certain nombre d'activités ou
de formation alors le président élu leur
a promis aux syndicats une nouvelle
méthode y avoir une conférence sociale
oui et on s'attend alors à quoi peut-on
s'attendre on sait pas exactement mais
c'est vrai que cette grande conférence
sociale ça rappelle d'autres conférences
social c'est un exercice un peu éculé ça
fait un peu ancien monde et d'ailleurs
les syndicats se disent ça va être
encore de l'affichage alors laurent
berger est un peu plus tolérant en
disant faites un grand rendez vous mais
c'est vrai qu'il va falloir qu emmanuel
macron soit un peu inventif parce que
qu'est-ce qui aura vraiment à négocier
dans cette conférence sociale c'est la
question que pose des syndicats on a
l'impression par exemple que sur la
réforme des retraites tout est un peu
déjà décidé d' avance emmanuel macron
sait très bien où il veut aller et puis
pouf souvenir que pour emmanuel macron
les syndicats ça reste des freins à la
réforme
alors c'est vrai qu'ils ont du mal à
mobiliser et qu'ils ont un travail à
faire pour retrouver un peu de la de
leur splendeur mais c'est vrai aussi que
pendant ce quinquennat emmanuel macron
n'a eu de cesse de les mettre sur la
touche les a fragilisés alors est ce que
c'est une bonne chose d'avoir des
syndicats comme ça qui sont mis de côté
dans une démocratie c'est un peu
dangereux emmanuel macron on a fait les
frais puisque vous avez plus
d'intermédiaires avec qui négocier et
puis ça laisse place à de la
contestation sociale beaucoup plus
inflammable que vous ne pouvez pas
contrôler et évidemment on pense au
gilet jaune ça a coûté cher à emmanuel
macron il se souvient donc à charge pour
lui cette fois-ci de trouver des façons
de travailler avec eux laurent berger
parle de concots construire des réformes
alors dans les syndicats il ya aussi
toute la mouvance des associations
caritatives en environnementale et ce
1er mai ils ont tous décidé de se réunir
un peu comme un grand barnum pour
montrer à emmanuel macron qu'ils
existent qu'ils sont là qui va falloir
faire avec eux un 1er mai entre une
élection présidentielle est un scrutin
législatif c'est un vrai tour de chauffe
fera la démonstration de force séquencer
dimanche ses dix mois vous vous y croyez
à la nouvelle méthode jean rémy c'est
emmanuel macron écoutant fanni je me
disais bon
a promis une nouvelle méthode est il là
il est au pied du mur évidemment bah ça
va dépendre aussi du des messages et
j'en parlais un peu dans ma chronique
mais deux des messages politiques qui va
envoyer à travers son nouveau
gouvernement est ce que ce sera un
gouvernement à l'écouté tout est ce que
ce sera un gouvernement très fermé si
vous avez un gérald darmanin à matignon
ça pathétique alors ce sera pas tout à
fait le signalement de prêt évidemment
on termine avec delphine alors énorme
rachat pour moi c'était une surprise
vous allez me dire si pour vous aussi
ces lots de masques multimilliardaire
américain qui rachète le géant twitter
mais pour 44 milliards de dollars ce qui
n'est pas du tout une offre au rabais 1
pour un réseau social qui cherche encore
son modèle économique mais le patron de
space xt cela lui était vraiment très
déterminés mais pourquoi il est
important ce rachat alors c'est pas du
tout anodin ce qu'on parle de twitter
c'est pas un réseau social où on y va
pour se faire des amis partager ses
photos de vacances est vraiment devenue
une rennes politique internationale et
d'ailleurs les réactions immédiates et
inquiète je dirais de personnalités
notamment du monde politique le prouve
pourquoi pour qui les inquiètent en fait
c'est qu'on a affaire à un libertarien
donc elon musk est un militant de la
liberté d'expression mais en version
absolue et il estime qu'elle n'est pas
suffisante aujourd'hui sur twitter dont
ce qui peut quand même surprendre voire
1 qui s'est passé relativement voilà
débridée on va dire disons quand même
les moyens qui sont déployés aujourd'hui
par le réseau social twitter pour
modérer les propos de haine de cyber
harcèlement on les trouve plutôt faible
au regard du volume qui est produit
chaque jour donc aux etats-unis en tout
cas des l'annonçons à du côté des
démocrates des réactions de peur presse
quand on parle de danger pour la
démocratie
le président des états unis lui qui
n'est pas non plus un fervent défenseur
dillon musk s'inquiète dit s'inquiéter
depuis longtemps du pouvoir de ses
grandes plateformes de réseaux sociaux
sur nos vies quotidiennes ça c'est le
porte-parole de la maison blanche qui le
rappelle et puis en europe alors qu'on
est en train de signer là des textes
importants pour davantage réguler le
pouvoir de ces plateformes bien
commissaire européen thierry breton a
jugé utile de poster sur twitter une
forme d'avertissement
qu'il s'agisse de voitures ou de
plateformes numériques nous dit il toute
entreprise opérant en europe de se
conformer à nos règles et monsieur
muscle c'est très bien alors oui il le
sait en effet mais beaucoup redoutent
quand même une avalanche de
désinformation avec en prime le retour
de donald trump pourquoi pas sur le
réseau social alors qu'est ce qui le
motive elon musk pourquoi il fait ça
pourquoi il rachète twitter alors je
disais déjà les comptes de twitter mais
le milliardaire lui-même 1
10 c'est pas du tout pour faire de
l'argent la vraie première motivation
c'est de motivation idéologique et puis
surtout on se retrouve dans une
situation absolument inédite puisque
sans vouloir faire de procès d'intention
sur la manière dont elon musk pourrait
tirer avantage finalement d'avoir la
mainmise sur un réseau social comme
twitter qui est aujourd'hui il nous dit
lui même il appelle ça la place publique
où se jouent des questions vitales pour
l'avenir de l'humanité et le new york
times ne manque pas de souligner par
exemple les intérêts qu'à elon musk à
travers tesla en chine qui pourrait
avoir une influence sur le réseau social
ou même en ôtant tout ça il faut
rappeler que lon me c'est l'homme le
plus riche du monde déjà aujourd'hui
l'un des plus influents il est puissant
dans deux industries stratégiques qui
sont le spatial et l'automobile est donc
maintenant avec la mainmise sur ce qui
est plus important réseau de diffusion
des idées dans le monde il est vraiment
dans une situation qui n'est sans pareil
comparable à sabou pas forcément au
lycée c'est pas bon pour vous pensez ce
sera chasse inquiétant écoutez moi je ne
suis pas inquiet peau pour le rachat
c'est à dire je sens ce n'est pas comme
si jusqu'à aujourd'hui
twitter avait été inspiré par des
principes comme ça de dialogue humaniste
alors que maintenant tout va bien
comparer la régulation
on ne peut plus être dans une dimension
où on se préoccupe des intentions d'un
mark zuckerberg plutôt que aujourd'hui
d'un îlot masque propriétaire de twitter
et où ces personnages là et donc ses
réseaux ou un pouvoir de ce type mais
évidemment on ne peut plus être on ne
peut pas être dans une situation où on
se remet aux bonnes intentions aux
mauvaises intentions des uns ou des
autres il faut une régulation et une
dissidence essais et certains un peu de
se mettre en place en europe avec quel
rythme on verra ça parce qu'elle admet
ce qui va très très vite actuellement
merci infiniment merci du lino d'empoli
ruez vous sur le match du kremlin c'est
absolument haletant et on apprend
énormément de chose merci à vous les
affranchis a très vite très belle soirée
documentaire mamba sur l'eau du rhône
prixtel tout de suite très belle soirée
à demain
[Musique]